everywhere you look that's all you
observe you observe predators and prey
and animals eating vegetables and that's
it
hmm and I think that this this concept
of overcoming adversity so it's so human
it's so a part of what we are then I
want to bring it back to you because one
of the things that I've been considering
is that I've said this many times and I
just had a conversation with my good
friend Steve Rinella the other day where
he brought it up independently he said I
think Jordan Peterson is the most
misunderstood and misinterpreted guy in
the world
he's like people are always like not
just misinterpret but miss stating what
you believe in misstating what you say
this opposition to you this I mean like
we were talking about this GQ interview
which I thought was I thought that woman
was far more intelligent than the and
and her approach was far better and far
more reasoned and well thought-out than
some of the other attacks on you before
so they're bringing in the varsity level
players is what I'm saying but I think
this is important I think this is part
of what with what forges this message is
that you are and you and this one of the
things that Eric Weinstein and I had
said about you is that you're
essentially the the hoist Gracy of the
intellectual dark web if you don't know
what that means is the early days of the
UFC no one knew what the best martial
art was and the idea was like there was
all these martial arts that are running
around independently and that they were
all claiming that they had the best
technique and let's see what happens and
hoist gracie was the one who represented
jiu-jitsu and went out there and beat
all these people with superior technique
and superior strategy south american yes
he's from brazil
yeah okay and he launched this Brazilian
Jiu and his family launched this
Brazilian jiu-jitsu empire that has
since taken over the world of martial
arts but you are the one who's
consistently engaging in these people
you're the one who's involved these
valley to toe events where you're
debating these people who are coming at
you hostile with notes and I think is
uncomfortable as those moments are like
who was the woman that said so what
you're trying to say
Numan gasps her I think her approach I
think she misunderstood you I think she
underestimated you I think she
misinterpreted who you are and she
thought that she could come at you with
this straw man sort of article and
argument rather in frame your positions
in a very unflattering way it just
didn't work no it just was it was like
the early days of hoist Gracie guys
would come out I'm flailing and he'd get
them in an armbar and they tap out and
they'd go [ __ ] that's kind of what
happened with you but now this woman who
you had this conversation with in GQ she
was much more skilled you know she was
better verbally she beat her her
arguments made more sense you have seen
more reasonable more well-read you know
she was able to think on her feet
quicker but still these are really
important conversations well it was a
funny day because I went to the to the
hotel room in Baltimore you know and I
went out of my way to do it and she was
hostile to me the second I walked into
the room really yes and and that really
kind of put me off what is it how so
well she basically told me that we were
going to have a war you know not so many
words that that but just there was a
coldness to her and distaste for me that
was sort of radiating from her she had
a-- she was animus possessed from a
union perspective that's the right way
of thinking about it one of the ways of
thinking about that is that she had a
chip on her shoulder and relationship to
me so she had already formulated who I
was in her imagination and she it was
also maybe a form of projection so like
I was the embodiment of all the things
that she found distasteful and that's
who she was so there was no there was no
willingness to consider on her part that
I could be different than her
preconceptions of yes right and so she
was she was hostile to me in the way
that you would be if you were prejudiced
against someone right from the beginning
and so by the time it was uncomfortable
in the room and by the time and there
was a photo shoot and so by the time the
conversation started I was more
impatient than I would normally be
because one of the things that I do
expect from journalists and Kathy Newman
was like this by the way and so of some
of the other people that go on have gone
after me at least they had the
professionalism to be civil before the
interview started no like because
there's a certain amount of politeness I
would say that not that I'm owed but
that someone you're interviewing is owed
yes if they come out of their way to go
talk to you it's like it's just human
decency
yes so there's no real conflict right
until you have this conflict it's just
hello nice to meet you yes thank you for
coming to human beings interacting with
each other yes yes well on relatively
profession well even just professional
right and just professional grounds it's
like well we're both here to do a job
and I've agreed to come but but no see
there was palpable enmity in the air
right to begin with and you know what I
actually thought at the end of that
interview I thought jeez you know maybe
I'm maybe I've done enough interviews
because I found that I was more
impatient than I would have liked to
have been now luckily it doesn't seem to
have gone overboard because I've been
watching the comments on that GQ
interview and I think it's got about
four and a half million views some
ridiculous number of views and people
have said that I was more impatient and
a little harsher than usual which i
think is true and I thought God you know
maybe I'm starting to run out of
patience which isn't good right right I
don't want to run out of patience
because then it it will flavor the
message that you're putting out
definitely and people will take it in
the wrong way and they'll take it in
with that bitterness yes exactly well
you know one of the things that I think
is very important is that you don't
become resentful I can and well and and
you know when I'm on this tour for
example like there's no resentment for
me because you think well this is you
might think well this is a lot of work
and I've been running around like mad
and and you know it takes a lot of
organization and it's quite demanding
and all of that and that's all true and
that none of that is a complaint and I
decided with Tammy right at the
beginning that well first of all that
this was going to be work and not a
vacation
because we're not stupid we know you
can't have everything at the same time
if you have any sense you're lucky if
you get some things that are good at
once you know so we're very grateful to
have that opportunity and that I was
going to continue to do
as long as I was thrilled to be in front
of the audience and then when I meet
people afterwards that I'm not looking
at the end of the line to see when the
night ends you know because I want to be
sure that every single person that comes
to meet me I'm you know president
present for absolutely cuz I am I am
actually quite taken aback and thrilled
I guess is the right word grateful grats
better us that they're there it's like
God man some of these people you know
like I was in they're coming from all
over the place you know people fly in
from Australia into Europe they've
they've flown they've flown it's lots of
Eastern Europeans came to England like
they're making huge tracks or as guys
who came from like eight they took him
like 12 hours to get through Russia to
come to Finland to watch the talk there
you know and and and then not just a few
people like that people are really gone
way the hell out of their way you know
and then and then they line up and it's
not that it's not inexpensive because
these venues are expensive and and all
of that and I'm well I'm I'm do it and
it's the same with the damn interviews
it's like I'm doing my best to not take
any of this for granted and not get
annoyed about it and and that goes for
the conflict too it's like well you know
I've tried to have my agent screen out
maybe the more egregious interviews you
know the ones that would just be nothing
but combat because there I find them
quite stressful though I wouldn't say
I'm hiding from them but you don't know
to begin with how an interview is going
to go and I could just say well I'm done
having interviews and for a while but I
I can't help but see that the conflict
is a necessary part of this even though
I don't find it pleasant like people
think they accused me of being a
provocateur of enjoying the conflict
it's actually not true at all I don't
enjoy it at all it usually takes me
about three days to recover from like
for a particularly contentious interview
you know because I find it I find
conflict interpersonal conflict quite
stressful yes you know but I think we
one does yes and to pretend you don't
you're either a sociopath or you're a
liar yes yes well there are people
to enjoy that kind of intellectual
combat you know that they'd yeah and the
political types are more like that but
but I think they still afterwards feel
it and if they read the comments and
people are against them it's just that
the unease it carries well you would
think so I mean I don't even know how
people deal with it because I mean I'm
being fortunate because although you
know I've had a fair bit of negative
press coverage the comments in on
YouTube in particular which is where of
the bulk of them are and and I would say
among the general public have been
overwhelmingly positive I don't know
what the hell it would be like to be in
a world where that was reversed where
you know the majority of people are
against you I've seen Jesus I've seen it
happen with guests that I've had on the
show where I've met them afterwards and
you see a physical effect on them you
see them beaten down like Jesus Christ
those comments are so mean I'm like you
can't read those you can't read those
and you see how it's affecting them like
they can't sleep they really yeah it
[ __ ] with them they'll stay up for
nights you know it's not good it's it's
you're you're you're taking in all of
these opinions of hundreds if not
thousands of people that you don't even
know you know if they're coming from a
healthy place and and most of those
opinions they would not express it that
way if they were talking yeah I think
he'd get the same message across like I
think you were ignorant to these facts I
think you are biased in your perceptions
even if they had an opinion that was
unflattering the way that are express it
to you they'd be considerate about you
and your your feelings as a human being
and if they weren't you wouldn't take
into consideration what they're saying
because these guys just an [ __ ] yeah
right but when you just see it in type
we just see print it just doesn't it
just it could be a smart person it could
be a psycho it could be a fool
it could be anything well it's also
funny too because that the negative
comments that are part of social media
seemed to be just as potent as negative
comments in real life but the positive
comments don't seem to be as positive as
the positive comments in real life yes
like I don't they don't seem as real and
I guess that's partly because we're
wired you know to be more sensitive to
threat and to negative emotion because
well because we're we can be hurt it's
also healthy to to not stroke your ego
too much if you just like concentrate
only on there like like there's
something distasteful if you go to
someone's page and they just retweet all
the positive things that people say to
them cuz any has this sort of
reinforcing slightly people know that I
say something really positive to Jordan
he's gonna retweet me mm-hmm there are
some people that they engage in this
sort of Commerce mm-hmm you know like
you say something positive they retweet
you and you know it's it's a little it's
a little to strokey right now right
people get really into that stroking
their own butt yeah yeah well I guess
and yeah I guess the danger of that is
that possibility of that ego inflation
that you only want to avoid because
that's a bad idea
oh that's a very bad idea